-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-Award-winning actor
you know best from his roles
in shows such as "Boston Legal,"
"The Office," "The Practice,"
and, of course, "The Blacklist."
The 200th episode
of "The Blacklist"
airs this Sunday, March 19th,
here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Why are you in my home
at this hour? This is not okay.
-You're right. It's not.
I understand that.
And under any other
circumstances,
I wouldn't have imposed.
-Did you sleep here?
-A very quick catnap,
just on the bench over there.
Truly a half-hour at most.
And then the time it took
to put together breakfast.
You see, I was at Mount Vernon,
playing a very small part
in a Revolutionary War
reenactment
when I got to drinking
quite late
with the 1st Delaware Regiment.
One thing led to another.
Those Blue Hen boys really know
how to hold their whiskey.
-Please welcome back
to the show our friend
James Spader, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's James Spader.
Guys, it's very --
It's very rare to get
exciting news from the guest
while you walk
from there to here.
But you just whispered to me
some exciting news.
-I did. No, I saw Flaco live
in the park.
[ Laughter ]
I -- I was walking one day,
and there were
all these people crowded
around the base of this tree.
And then also lenses like this.
-Yeah.
-You know?
And they'd been parked there,
obviously, for some time.
And he was up in the tree.
And I saw him up there.
I will say this, though.
You know, I mean,
I don't want to,
you know, send any shade...
-Right.
Is this going to be anti-Flaco?
-...on your bet. No, no.
[ Laughter ]
no. I just --
I -- Really.
I'm, you know, in my --
I'm 63, and just this year
for the first time,
I heard, in multiple --
from multiple sources,
like, reading it in all --
in several different articles
just this year,
including an article
about Flaco,
that owls of the bird species
are actually incredibly stupid.
-Alright.
-So that expression...
-Okay.
-...of Flaco, who is like...
-Yeah.
You're saying
that maybe he wasn't
like, "How dare you guys,"
and that's more just how --
That's how he looks
all the time?
-He certainly --
He certainly wasn't like,
"What, do you think
I'm an idiot?"
No, it wasn't that.
-Okay.
-It was like, "Yeah?"
-Well, thanks for --
Thanks for settin' us
straight, James.
[ Laughter ]
I like that, like,
all of a sudden, what are you --
what are you --
Did you just start
reading bird books at 63
that you're like --
"Now I can't stop reading
how dumb owls are."
-Yeah, I really --
I don't know how it came about,
but it's amazing
how there's been such, you know,
a dichotomous narrative about
owls, like, particularly --
I mean, even the little pictures
you showed
is like the owl as a teacher.
-Yeah.
-And, you know,
it must be their sort of
furry eyebrows or something.
-Yeah,
but when you think about it,
I mean, obviously,
everybody I know --
every person I knew who slept
all day and was up all night,
they were dummies, too, so --
-Yes.
Amazing hearing.
-Yeah.
They -- It's very nice for you
to end this on an up note.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, they don't understand
a thing they hear.
-Just doing my part.
-So, 200 episodes.
This is the final season
of this incredible show.
Congratulations.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And -- I mean,
shows don't run
like this anymore.
You received a --
This is lovely.
There was --
You know, sometimes I think
people might not know this.
When you hit a milestone,
the show will give out
sort of a crew gift
to everybody.
-Yes, I mean, there's enormous
amount of gift-giving, you know,
around the corporate culture
of all kinds, you know.
-Yeah.
-But -- And on sets, too.
You know,
and it's a very strange thing,
I think, in that --
You know, every --
everybody earns a good living
on our show, you know?
And -- But, like,
we'll give the cast,
and the producers will give
the whole crew,
you know, a Christmas gift.
-Yeah.
-This year, it was
an electronically heated vest.
-Very nice. Very thoughtful.
-But, you know,
we all know each other
really well, you know?
We all work together every day
and so on and so forth.
So it's a different thing.
You know, so whoever it is
who's in charge of, you know,
picking out corporate gifts
from the studio
or the network
to the cast members or the crew,
you know, they don't
really know anybody at all.
-Yeah.
-And they're getting presents
for people that,
as I said, you know,
can afford their things.
The only person who probably
can't very well
is the person who's
having to decide on that gift.
-Right.
-You know, that's probably --
-The one person who can
actually use the gift, right.
-The one person who could
really use the gift, you know.
Anyway -- [ Laughs ]
I remember I did a show
for some time for ABC
called "Boston Legal."
-Of course.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Of course.
-And, you know, it was
a fairly successful show.
It won a whole bunch of Emmys,
and, you know, it did very well.
And I remember once,
sort of late in the game,
I got a gift at one point
from ABC,
and it was a Tiffany box
from Tiffany's store.
And I was, "Oh, great.
This --
What's this going to be?"
And I open it up,
and it was a bracelet.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-A silver cuff.
-Bracelet.
-And did you immediately think,
"I'm never going to wear this"?
-Well --
I mean, I didn't really
even know what to do with it...
-Yeah.
-...let alone wear it.
But -- Anyway.
Yeah, so this year --
Well, for the 100th episode,
our entire cast and crew
got TVs.
-Alright. Well, that's --
that's very nice.
-Very nice.
-Yeah.
-I mean, they were small
black-and-whites with antennas.
[ Laughter ]
-Sure.
-A separate VHF and UHF.
-Of course.
Yeah, well, I mean,
they've got to get it
for a bunch of people, you know?
-A TV nonetheless.
-Yeah.
-No. We got really nice TVs.
-And that's a, you know,
thoughtful gift.
Everybody needs one.
-You know, that was
the 100th episode.
So then, now think like
a hundred episodes later,
so that's several seasons,
right?
So, my gift arrived in my
dressing room, but it was...
[ Laughter ]
I always think of the --
You know, I'm --
I'm --
[ Laughter ]
I earn a very respectable
salary, you know?
And I feel like,
you know, you --
The salary that you earn
is based on, you know,
how much they like the show...
-Sure.
-...and how successful
the show is
and, you know, how much
they like your contribution
to the show and everything.
And I feel like the gift
that you get
is how much they like you.
-Uh-huh. Yeah, yeah.
-Wouldn't you think?
-I see. Right.
So the salary is for the work.
-For the work.
-The gift is personal.
-And then the gift is --
Yeah, because it's gratuitous.
-This is James, the person.
-It's completely gratuitous.
I don't need a gift really,
you know?
-Yeah.
-It's a -- It's a gesture.
It's how much we like you.
My agents,
they always give me wine.
-Yeah. Do you like wine?
-I love wine.
-Perfect.
[ Laughter ]
-So, this came in an Hermes bag.
-Okay.
-And I thought, "Wow."
-Yeah.
-"They really like me."
-This is an expensive store.
And I took it out,
and it was just
a square of leather.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh-huh.
-Which I've seen before,
you know?
I -- You know, like, when --
We just did a renovation
at our house,
and I was sent the same thing
as a sample
to what we might want
to cover the couch with.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-You know?
-So it was like --
it was like a leather sample?
-It was like a leather sample.
It's Hermes.
I thought maybe it's a sample
for what's possible
to make a saddle out of.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-I really didn't have any idea
what it was.
-Gotcha.
-So I called my friend Laura
who works upstairs,
literally and figuratively.
And so she came
to my dressing room,
and I said,
"What the hell is this?"
Because I was
about to go downstairs...
-Yeah.
-...to -- There were going
to be people there that --
-That had given it to you.
-Not really.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Anyway, I said, "What is this?"
And she said, "Oh. Yes.
I got the same thing.
[ Laughter ]
It's a mouse pad."
I mean, I -- Truly, I didn't
even really know what she meant.
[ Laughter ]
I don't own a computer.
-Right.
-You know, I thought
it was the place
where your domesticated mouse
goes to the bathroom.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't know -- True story.
Backstage in your dressing room,
I said,
"Oh, I'll send you
a link to something."
And you looked at me --
You gave me
a real Flaco the Owl look
when I said "link."
So I -- I can appreciate
that a mouse pad did not --
was not straight to your heart.
[ Laughter ]
-I feel much better about Flaco.
He could do a TV show.
-James, you know my favorite
thing about having you here?
-Yeah.
-Because our time is almost up,
so I want to tell you my --
-It always is.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't think you've ever --
Of any guest I've ever had here,
i don't think you've ever told
two stories.
[ Laughter ]
And you don't ever have to.
[ Cheers and applause ]
For my money,
you don't ever have to.
The one, the only --
James Spader, everybody.
200th episode of "The Blacklist"
airs this Sunday, March 19th,
at 10:00 p.m. here on NBC.
We'll be right back
with Ian McShane.